he's not a groper he's not Hitler he  isn't a bully he's not a phony  politician he's not a fan of  teleprompters he's not a Democrat he's  not a member of the political class he's  not a Republican he's not a conservative  and I'm not a politician I'm not a  debater I'm not the president right now  i am not a fast drinker i'm not a  masochist I'm not a bad person I'm not  passive at all I'm not a bully now I'm  not a bully at all I'm not a Shrieker of  economies I'm not against any religion  I'm not thin skin I'm not a full person  I'm not an angry person I'm not an Obama  person I'm not a conspiracy person I'm  not a fan of Bernie I'm not a cutter I'm  not an isolationist I am NOT an extreme  as I'm not stupid okay i can tell you  that